and that brings us to our final topic
this week which I completely forgot
because it sweet it's about weed people
me ganja dope wow that was wild they say
it affects your short-term memory it is
quite possible and I think we just saw
evidence of it so I love this another
Republican we're gonna combine
Republicans and weed into one thing
another one an aunty weed guy and guess
what he did he's smoking weed Steve Katz
up in up in New York and so there's a
couple different ways we can go here but
let's start with this R is any
politician not a hypocrite before we get
to the hardcore weed stuff is anyone
that's telling you not to do anything in
your private life not a hypocrite in
their own life Brian first yes yes there
is one guy oh no no it's not out of
course I don't know of course not i mean
when i read this story i was like of
course this happen you know it's it's
not it's not my kind of shocker you know
i mean it's it's it's like one of those
things where i remember my parents
telling me one time that they smoked
with the neighbor when i was growing up
and I was like really you know my
parents but then again it's probably not
that shocking and you really think about
it you know everyone smoked weed at some
point in their life well I'm sure your
parents will be happy that this is now
out there on the internet everyone knows
oh gosh mr. and mrs. Nolan out in I
believe there in California all right
fart all right we'd where do you fall on
the weed thing because everybody look it
to me it's going to it's going to help
the economy you can start taxing it
let's just talk about the broader weed
topic weird look working in local news
I've been convinced by some people who I
respect that it's still an issue and
it's an issue they think that requires
it to continue being outlawed so you
know I don't four days ins uh you know
look the Sacramento County Sheriff who I
have a whole lot of respect for you in
California will tell you ten different
reasons why he has seen from arrest to
parents what it does to households what
it does to children he don't think it's
a good idea drinking is the same thing
essentially i'm not saying i'm right but
it's something i don't use and it's
something I don't you know I mean we'll
see what happens is it inevitable maybe
what I love about these types of stories
is it makes
tissues like this guy seem human because
they go out there and they're like you
know you better and in a way I'm better
than you and then he's running off to
smoke down well and the funny thing
about what this guy was the bill that he
helped veto was to legal legalize
medicinal marijuana not even
recreational like he was smoking weed to
get high to have fun exactly and he
didn't want people to help themselves
medically now I want to ask the
dreadlock member of the panel what she
thinks marijuana is amazing yeah yes of
being a parking lot carolee um now you
know I understand what you're saying you
know but at the same time I think a
there's bigger fish to fry in politics
and in the world and you know I
definitely think that as you were saying
about alcohol alcohol is definitely more
damaging not only to the human body but
also to you know just families yeah
exactly I've never really had someone
you know OD on weed or get you know they
have their little sweet and breaks into
a bag I think or yeah you've never seen
somebody just completely lose their [ __ ]
because they're they smoked a bowl you
know and and it's just like I do
appreciate I do think that you know it
does humanize these politicians because
you know people take these stances and
they're so strict on it but it's like
you know yeah it's you're obviously you
have hypocritical things it's just don't
be so staunch is basically what I'm
saying like don't be so damn staunch if
you know you're doing it yourself like
if you're gonna be strict on something
just choose something that you know
you're not gonna go home and light up
when you get back it isn't this another
one of these bizarre cases where the
Republicans who like to say that they're
all for freedom and individual liberty
and you can do what you want your house
and it should have nothing to do with
the government but they want to get all
up in women's wombs and they want to
regulate how much we just smoked or let
that you smoke it at all etcetera
etcetera so it seems like a bit of it's
not even something ain't jivin with me
about it back it's a little thank you
Brian yeah well I mean they do they do
still want to regulate absolutely as
much as they want to remove tons of
government they absolutely want to
regulate what I think that they
associate marijuana with a liberal mind
you know I think that that's what they
want to kind of regulate over what's
next they're tracking my anus you know
the wounds that you know well on that
note my glaucoma's been acting up so I
think I'm gonna take the panelists out
to the parking lot and we'll see what's
what I thank you guys for watching and
this has been the Reuben report we'll
see you next week don't forget the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
is bonobos calm enter code trr 20 for
twenty percent off your next shirt